when vaccination is the clearest route
out of the pandemic
speed matters and the uk is a world
leader
with some in government believing that
all adults could be offered their first
dose by the summer
but it's not the offer of a job that
matters it's whether people
actually get it and lower uptake of the
vaccine among britain's ethnic minority
community
is a serious concern people from black
asian and minority ethnic groups are
more likely to die from covet clovid19
than white people
but there's also higher levels of
hesitancy towards the vaccine
birmingham lady wood is one of the most
diverse constituencies in the country
their labour mp shibana mahmoud says
she's filled in calls from worried
constituents
regularly what i've been picking up from
doctors
and other people on the front line in my
constituency is that
there is much more vaccine hesitancy
among some of our
black asian and other ethnic minority
communities
uh they're picking up many more people
who are saying no and that they don't
want the vaccine
um and they are concerned about it so
you know that's been flagged with me by
local gp practices in my own
constituency and i know that others in
birmingham are doing the same
figures from the royal college of gps
shared exclusively with safety ridge on
sunday
shows that 91 of people who received a
vaccine are white
and only 5 come from asian backgrounds
just 2
to black and 1 mixed race
to put it another way 14 of white people
have received at least one dose so far
compared to just nine percent of asian
people seven percent of black people
and five percent who are mixed race
white people are twice as likely to have
had a vaccine than black people
and more than three times more likely
than the mixed race population
barriers to healthcare access could be a
factor and some argue that a wider lack
of trust is at play
there's a general mistrust of the nhs
because there's some history certainly
in the uk as well as abroad
which have not been good and and these
are
validated from royal colleges so they're
like the princess of the royal college
of
midwives royal college of obstetrics and
gynecology tell us about the very poor
outcomes
for black and ethnic minority people
in respect to pain control during uh
delivery and indeed still births etc
so one's got to ask why is that
there are issues of course well known in
the field of psychiatry
where a lot of younger black people are
grossly overrepresented
and people have done the the matching
analysis they are sectioned
much more quickly uh they are given
various
drug regimes much more quickly than
their white counterparts so there is
this general mistrust
dr michael dawes is a junior doctor from
birmingham who's been on the front line
in the fight against coping 19 since the
beginning
he's been shocked at some of the things
he's heard from nurses on his own wards
it really shocked me when nurses would
actually go and tell people
don't take the vaccine but what really
got me the most is when i heard
one of the nurses i supposed to say come
on you know you call your black nurses
auntie come on nancy we need to go get
this vaccine
and she's like no my pastor said
no and i'm like whoa and that shocked me
it got me angry and i said to her
give me your pastor's number and let me
speak to your pastor don't let
misinformation put you or your loved
ones
at risk mps have been trying to
encourage their constituents to get
vaccinated
with a video from a cross-party group of
black mps presenting a united front
i will be taking the vaccine i'll be
taking the vaccine when it's my turn
i'll be taking the vaccine
but outside of westminster community
action is seen as key
and some doctors have their own
strategies to get the message out
i've been researching and asking people
what is it that we can do as healthcare
professionals to help
build that trust back i think that in
order for
us to be effective in vaccinating the
black community
we have to go about that level of trust
we've already done a
vaccination program where we talked
about it
where we gave people the opportunity to
ask questions
and we give them the answers and if any
answers that we don't have
we go and seek them out and and point
them in the right direction
widespread support for this kind of
community-based action but there are
also
calls for the government to tailor their
messaging more towards different
communities
the messaging i've said is paramount
what it has to be good
it has to be consistent it has to have
transparency
and most of all honesty and i'm
unfortunately in in these categories
in quite a few situations i think this
government has come up short what
governments have to do they have to
harness members of those communities
members who are trusted uh members who
are well known
you know from the spectrum of the age
groups be it footballers
get poor marcus rashford but the
rashfords and the sterlings
the lenny henry's people are well known
faces
they have to get those people involved
in the messaging
and also very importantly at the
community level you have to engage
with community leaders with the church
leaders or the mosque leaders
and that's happening to some extent that
is the way you're going to do
do well not by some top-down comments
the royal college of gp says that if the
government doesn't get a grip
on vaccine take-up particularly among
communities worst hit by the virus
kofi 19 could remain a threat in some
parts of the uk
for much much longer
it may be a bit early to speak of
britain's vaccine success
just yet